the ski industry in colorado is hoping
desperately for a white christmas ski
slopes in the rocky mountain state are
usually packed with snow ahead of the
holidays but look at what they look like
now with virtually no snow on the ground
there it is
colorado's in the middle of its longest
snow drought in decades and ski resorts
well they're starting to feel a little
nervous mark straussman is in steamboat
springs with more on this story mark how
does that song go let it snow let us
know let us know
and they're singing it here gail believe
me a steamboat is one of the premier
resorts here in colorado where skiing is
a roughly 5 billion a year industry but
see that gondola behind me the last time
it took skiers up this mountain was back
in the spring
we're in december and yet today's
temperatures are supposed to be in the
low 40s
too little snow too much warm weather
have added up
steamboat ski report patchy at best
people just really want to get out and
we just don't have enough snow
170 trails here five open 17 chairlifts
only one this one shuttling skiers up
the mountain i've been in the ski
industry for 20 years and i've never
really seen it like this steamboat's
lauren duke told us all the snow you see
here
man made we're only using one percent of
the resort to offer skiing and riding at
this time we would love to have more
terrain open in early december typically
30 percent of steamboat's trails have
skiers
this map of colorado ski resorts shows
the paltry percentages of available
terrain and many of the iconic
destinations in american skiing we've
seen about 50 percent of average
snowpack across the state of colorado
meteorologist joel gratz founded open
snow which forecasts snow falls for
resorts here he blames climate change
for this warm december weather people
are definitely paying attention
to the lack of snow thankfully we still
have a couple of weeks to go until the
busiest holiday period and people are
still coming to colorado steamboat has
100 staffers making snow or trying to
but in this warm weather snow guns and
trail groomers have little chance
ideal snow making temperature about 27
degrees what's the temperature here
temperature right now here is probably
around 41.
that's not even close we're probably
about 50 percent behind on our total
snowmaking hours right now compared to
where we would normally be skiers are
both thrilled and frustrated to be out
here crowded very crowded there's only a
couple runs that are open so
very crowded
but there is some hope in the forecast a
snowstorm tomorrow another one expected
next week two storms when this area
really could use four and with the
important christmas
skiing season coming up there's a lot of
pressure on these storms to deliver both
snow and cold temperatures
tony
yeah mark those pictures just don't look
right thank you very much i i guess the
the overall temperatures also affect the
kitty hills where i would be on
the tubing hills where i might be on
yeah i mean you guys skiers the sledding
of hills
right for you no but i feel for the
people that love to ski and you know
it's a big tradition for a lot of people
to go to colorado and get in and to ski
it's tough to look at those just seeing
green grass where snow is supposed to be
this time of year that's shocking it's a
big it's a big economic hit and there's
also serious questions about what it
means climate change-wise going forward
so mark thank you very much you get at
least one ride in